The answer is: two.
The value of the "q" parameter in our HTML was "two"
so when we submit the form, we should see "two" in the URL.
Let's go ahead and try it out.
Here we are in our browser; we can see the second radio button is selected,
and when I click Submit, q=two in the URL.
That's because the second radio button--
"one", "two", "three"--its value is "two".
Pretty straightforward.
Keep in mind that the meaning of these parameters
is whatever we make of it, on the Server side.
So on the Server side, we can look for the variable "q"
or the parameter "q", and do what we want with it--
or we can ignore it altogether.
We can check to see if it equals "on"
or we can check to see if it equals "one", "two" or "three".
That's all up to us, and we'll talk more about that
when we start working with our Server side app again.